and while the impeachment inquiry heats
up in Washington the president is
clashing with other Western leaders at
that NATO summit in London he took jabs
at Canadian Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau yesterday saying Canada had
fallen behind in its military spending
he also argued with French president
Emmanuel macron over Syria and all of
this threatens to widen the gap between
the US and its NATO allies Paula Reed is
in London traveling with the president
Paula good morning what's going on with
the summit right now a good morning Tony
the leaders are currently meeting at a
Golf Resort outside London where they
are expected to discuss threats from
terrorism to arms control even the
emergence of China but it appears the
greatest threat to this alliance it's
actually the tension among its members
over what exactly NATO should be leaders
of the 29 NATO member alliance countries
were all smiles as they posed for the
ceremonial family photo this morning in
London but less than 24 hours earlier
some awkward moments between President
Trump and close us partners ruled the
day including French President Emmanuel
macron in a tense exchange Tuesday
macron challenged President Trump on his
handling of Syria unaccustomed to direct
confrontation by leaders abroad mr.
Trump fired back would you like some
nice Isis fighters don't make any
mistake you're number one problem are
most foreign fighters this is this is
why he's a great politician because that
was one of the greatest for years mr.
Trump has railed against NATO calling it
obsolete and demanding members pay more
but on the 70th anniversary of the
alliance mr. Trump has been much more
embracing of the partnership even while
casting doubt on whether he would commit
to defending any nation that falls short
of pulling their weight financially well
that's okay
Hey seated next to Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau mr. Trump called
out the country for its contribution to
NATO
I have just slightly delinquent hours
later Prime Minister Trudeau was caught
on camera
apparently mocking mr. Trump at a palace
reception
[Music]
President Trump has just responded to
those remarks by Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau president Trump suggested
the Prime Minister was quote two-faced
and that he was actually just upset that
President Trump jabbed him over Canada's
contributions to NATO today the
president will host a lunch for other
members who have met their financial
commitments to the Alliance and just
moments ago the president has canceled
his press conference that was scheduled
for this afternoon suggesting he's
already answered enough questions thank
you very much Paula Reid reporting from
London